hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play my only now
this is another pixelated style horror
game so if you like seven days and I
will kill you in kilobyte and you're
gonna love this one
if you don't well then please watch it
anyway because I'm here and it's the
first video I've recorded in a long time
mmm it's been so long now since the
tides had taken her I knew her well
loved her so and will never hold her
again how her touch still haunts me I
must return to her and set myself astray
to do what I must to leave this all
behind dun dun dun dun dun da da dun dun
dun my one
my only dun-dun-duh okay enough there
I'm sorry I'm sorry everybody I'm just a
little excited to be back in recording
because it has been a nice long vacation
but I do miss work okay so it's raining
I'm in the woods looks as mine crafty as
ever but I'm going to continue forward
and see if I can't find a place to throw
myself into the ocean which is what I
can only assume that I want to do
because they said something about the
tides taking her II left like the gate
won't open what do you know about that
what a big surprise okay let's find
something else here that we can utilize
and err to be able to open this gate
which I'm guessing is some sort of a key
mechanism hello I heard some there no I
hear that is that just part of the
ambiance or a lie actually going crazy
it's a little early for me to be going
crazy don't you think hello read page 2
my dearly beloved I remember how we used
to dance about the world without care
how we endeared every moment we had to
each other why did all that have to
change
dun dun dun ah selected one of 12 pages
what is his surrender god I hope not
for multiple reasons this game actually
I've been following for a while because
it's been in development for quite a
long time so I can tell based on the
other games that I played that this one
actually has a bit of quality to it
because I've never seen rain before and
the audio work is very very well done ok
so I seem to be traipsing around the
wood finding certain landmarks this
seems to be slender
yes why doesn't this rain stop it's as
if the world itself wishes to drown me
as well please I did no wrong I just
want to be left alone okay I'm gonna try
to remember where I've been because I've
seemed to be wandering into a maze a
maze of dreams and nightmares from which
I cannot escape or something romantic
like that or Herpa derpa derpa I'm
trapped in the woods well it uh
markiplier that seems more like it what
am I trying to do being romantic and
Noble and whatnot I'm are black Irish
dude is gamer alive now that we're
thoroughly lost seem to be finding
nothing I finally realize that I have a
sprint button and I will use it to my
best advantage as I traipse around the
woods a little more running from who
knows what to find who knows why to go
who knows where what am I supposed to
tell him it was a mistake to betray his
love and trust he deserves so much more
from me what am I to do Oh Oh Lady you
cheat on me lady picked up the gate key
out okay why loo what what was that huh
you gonna do some time ha ha ha
oh it's a wall of water really ha ha ha
alrighty then
oh so this is how it's gonna be I see
what you're driving at I see what you're
going for
ah ha ha ha what the hell what
what's going on well I already got look
if you add water I'm not doing so good I
seem to be a little bit of a predicament
uh-oh that was water
ha ha I thought that was a skull that
really looked like a scary skull I'm not
doing so good hang on let me just
collect my thoughts and not run into any
more wah wah that's what I call water
it's wah wah okay I'm doing better ha ha
what the hell was that huh huh huh
you go yeah hey gum joke okay I seem to
be out of those crazy water woods and
now I'm carrying on to do did I go this
way yes I did okay so even the world
seems to be trying to drown me but I
have a gate key which means hang on let
me go this way I haven't gone this way
and I don't want to miss anything
important
yes to my dearly beloved since the day
you left me I've never been able to move
on even to this day I can hardly believe
that you're gone now and despite the
pain you've caused me I still remember
why I loved you please rest in peace mmm
there's some sort of a betrayal and some
unending guilt this man cannot live
without live with I open the lock and
stepped inside
the air was cold in most foreboding she
walked me from beyond
you killed it in you my hands could only
tremble as I shuddered within the core
my senses dulled and my breath turned
numb and yet somehow I carried on
because I am a badass and I probably
murdered my own wife yes that's what I'm
going to guess happened yeah quiet oh
boy a cemetery I can't believe it
how could I have allowed all this happen
it just can't be true
why did you die why did you have to die
for me because you you killed her you
murdering bastard
hello mr. flower collected one of 12
flowers gonna make a beautiful bouquet
for her grave I suppose poop I wonder if
I miss many more pages outside a b'doop
edge these places hearted even as I
speak the spirits of the departments
around me know there everybody
now's not the time to join the likes of
you leave me be Ravin sake leave me be
alrighty then you're going a little
crazy aren't you psycho boy yeah you go
a little out of your mind going a little
wacky bonkers a little bit good loo bit
okay I am far far too energetic for this
game just a wee bit just a wee bit too
energetic for this game
let's see more flowers don't mind me
picking flowers in the middle of a
cemetery perfectly normal behavior that
was inside this gate that somehow my
diary has been spread all around in
wound OHS who knows what's happening
I do not okay
aha more flowers for my beautiful
princess my beautiful corpse bride yes
is you love these and almost got all the
flowers just eat oats more ghosts or
[ __ ] in French ha ha alright ok it's not
12 I say I there's a spirit of the
haunted go a spirit of the haunted
namely my wife what I do wrong I said I
don't have your fast oh hello baby
haha you didn't tell me that you were
slightly disturbing but I guess I could
have already guessed that have I been I
bet I picked the flowers here hang on
your bouquet it's almost ready baby
baby this is her grave hang on baby baby
I got it but I got to get the flowers
gotta get the flowers baby please leave
me be I am almost done huh okay babbit
Maura but uh this is it I cannot lie to
him any longer
oh how foolish I was to turn him away
like that only now I've learned my
mistake tomorrow when we meet at the
shore I'll confess my sins to him
I pray he'll have it within himself to
love me still for what I've done
okay so apparently you cheated on me and
I went psycho bonkers lunatic II and
killed you I killed you dead and now I'm
haunted by my regret and my shame of my
crime okay put the flowers on a grave
for her the flowers were placed as a
token of my goodwill for her death had
been a part fate most cool
I could feel her by my side Aloha
the cold couldn't leave me neither did
it hide wane away for I knew not what
else to do as my memory slowly became
reality to a time when death had play
garland and Donna okay now finally we
have written this is this whole game is
just an exercise for my voice that I
like it I just can get as creative as I
want and where am I going
what oh oh oh oh this is it goodbye
cruel world
I'm gonna throw myself into the ocean
headfirst do a triple somersault
backflip corkscrew get a solid ten from
everybody about the Russian judge and
then die okay fine all right
let's let's do this dad what did wait a
minute oh dang haha hi before the sea
from which she lay she saw the pain of
my misery my torment would never end
until a soul free his last her corpse
emerge before me here she cried for me
from now she knew of my love still to
her and even in spite of death she would
love me forever more but still I could
not forget I had loved her once
and even in death I knew I may never
find love again oh that was it that was
really really cool I really enjoyed that
and I hope you guys didn't mind me going
a little silly because it was the first
game that I played a long time but it
was really really an interesting
experience like that was more
story-driven than I expected it to be
and I should have I should have taken
that much more seriously but you know as
I stated McGee exam I'm too pitous gamer
alive
I can't do anything right apparently I
don't even know if I did everything that
I was supposed to do there was a door
there that I didn't go in what hell but
I missed some did I miss some I promise
some I was overwhelmed by the guilt with
losing my love my guess is she told me
she cheated on me
I said her cue and she jumped into the
sea that's what I guess what happened
and then I was wracked by guilt because
I couldn't stand to be without her even
though she had betrayed me and that was
the good ending hey hey you're something
else in there anyway so try for yourself
apparently there's more that I have not
seen at least that's what I'm willing to
guess so anyway this has been an
excellent exercise for my voice I hope
you enjoyed my lyrical somber tones so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the a me with click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
bud
it all has